Вартість житла в Україні в іноземній валюті останніми роками зменшується
Пік цін на нерухомість був у серпні 2008-го
коли середня вартість квадратного метра житла у Києві
сягала трьох тисяч доларів
А коли ціни сягнули свого "дна" у лютому цього року
вартість квадратного метра у столиці трохи перевищувала тисячу доларів
Падіння цін майже втричі
Під час злету цін на нерухомість
в Україні у серпні 2008-го
курс долара становив менше п’яти гривень
і квадратний метр житла у Києві
в середньому коштував трохи більше 14 тисяч гривень
Під час найнижчих цін на житло у валюті у лютому 2017-го
за один долар давали вже близько 27 гривень
За метр житлової площі
це виходить понад 28 тисяч гривень
Тож попри зменшення втричі цінника у доларах
для українців житло стало не таким вже і доступним
Через інфляцію і девальвацію ціна за метр житла
у гривні стала удвічі більшою
Великою мірою погіршення добробуту українців
спричинене анексією Криму і війною на Донбасі
Однак також на це впливає і гальмування реформ
Доходи українців не встигають зростати відповідно
до темпів злету цін на продукти і комунальних тарифів
А купівля житла взагалі стає недосяжною
Через це торік Україна потрапила до переліку країн-лідерів
за рівнем втрати добробуту домогосподарствами
Україна стала другою країною у світі
після Аргентини
яка стрімко біднішала у 2016-му році
На третьому місці світового антирейтингу - Росія
Ціни на житло для українців не стали доступнішими, а радше навпаки
Попри зменшення вартості нерухомості
в Україні у доларах
через девальвацію національної валюти
ціни в гривнях зросли
А на тлі зростання цін
зменшився добробут населення
Незважаючи на поступову стабілізацію в економіці та збільшення кількості новобудов
багато житла залишається незатребуваним